and in a certain way it's extremely
let's call it spiritual
you could also say religious you could
say so the thing is it's very
mystical yeah and practically every word
our language is not made to this
it's really out the worldly you sort of
leave the realm of
of of something and go to another one so
so what i want to say is like the
language is not so easy this is why by
the way most religions
are based on psychedelics provenly
including christianity
and this is why they all use these
pictures and describe
things like the burning chair which or
for chariot which goes in the air
whatever
because they can't put actually their
experience really in words because there
are no words to describe a
director that's first yeah so and if i
do it then i need to use religious terms
are you shocked how the tech elite seem
to
hate the regular person like if you if
you ask the regular person like what do
you think the
the head of twitter or facebook or all
these people think about you they think
oh they want to censor us they don't
want us to
speak freely they want to own our data
and all of that stuff
so you're trying to basically rectify
that
well so what do you think that the
ordinary people hate the tech people or
the other way around
i think it's a little i think it's a
little bit of both but i consider myself
more of the regular person i think the
average
person thinks that the big tech people
just basically
you know think that their fodder for
whatever their algorithms want
and however they can make money
something like that
well meaning one other theory and i'm
copying that what i'm saying now you can
stop by original thought but like
one of the things what uh juwal harari
yeah
sort of uh coined was this idea that
if again if if humanity
i don't wanna say goes bad because i
still don't know i have not i have not
reached the conclusion if it's like
good or bad or neutral but it could be
hindsight like in 100 or 200 years we
might look at this time and say
we have split up in two species because
you have
a part of the humanity who says hey
bring it on
let's fly to mars and by the way one
very simple fact if you want to go to
mars
we're gonna need to change our body
because our body is not made
for not even mars travel not to talk
about space travel
yeah you die of cancer within some weeks
yeah so
if we want to go to mars it's not just
going to mars we're going to have to
modify
and nobody's talking about that but i
think everybody knows it right so that's
that's the whole transhumanism movement
basically exactly so
and by the way and you and it's gonna
happen because the we already have it
you have a heart
if you have a stent i think it's called
english like yeah so it is already a
mini technological intervention
like so and somehow we get comfortable
like and we're going to get more and
more and more but there might be a part
of the humanity who says
this is not for me yeah i don't want to
merge with
machines and again this sounds already
so sci-fi but
it's gonna gradually happen so so so
humanity might split into species and in
50 years 100 years we're gonna look back
and say well
that so and that's already like sort of
in a mini way happening now because you
have these one part of humanity who
wants
sort of go wider further
the sky's the limit like let's bring it
on and then you have and what i said
like
the other part who maybe doesn't really
it i don't want to say intellectually
because this sounds uh
degrading but i just like let's take a
positive example and i really mean it
positive and sorry by the way i'm not an
english speaker so
yeah so you're doing this a lot of
politically correctness things because i
always can say i didn't mean it that way
um so now we'll take a bus driver so he
or she
maybe can't explain you how autonomous
driving works
yeah but somehow i think humans always
have a very good gut feeling so as a
collective we're actually pretty smart
and somehow that bus driver knows
this is not going in the right direction
i'm not gonna be a bus driver in 10
years yeah
and and and that again makes him maybe
resent the people
yeah so again it comes back we need to
sort of take him or
her or whatever like on this sort of
thing okay so now
now link that to psychedelics for me so
no so that
many first of all i don't have an answer
on that like fully like because i just
think like
but i i think the bigger fear what i
have is that we don't even discuss the
problem we discuss so many [ __ ]
stuff
can i say well you can say anyway
so no but like this is i think this is
your point yeah this is the point of a
lot of friends we have that
a lot of discussions if you see the real
issue
like or the real problems yeah a lot of
discussions are
really observed because they're like why
don't but again
i see rather through the lens that i'm
looking here i understand why the people
have this discussion
take all the identity politics
it is again another form of tribalism
how
in the 1850s and following the people
invented
communism so to say and nationalism now
we're inventing
other crazy stuff yeah but it makes us
feel at home
it makes us feel us against the rest of
us so how do psychedelics come into it
so where do i start because it's like
it's very so one thing why i'm always
very
a little bit hesitating not just
anything like so it's very hard and i
have to describe a psychedelic trip
first yeah i was gonna ask you please
and in a certain way it's extremely
let's call it spiritual
you could all say religious you could
say so the thing is it's very
mystical yeah and practically every word
our language is not made
to just it's really out the worldly you
sort of leave the realm of
of of something go to another one so so
what i want to say is like the language
is not so
easy this is why by the way most
religions are based on psychedelics
provenly including christianity and this
is why they all use these pictures and
describe
things like the burning chair which or
chariot which goes in the air whatever
because they can't put actually their
experience
really in words because there are no
words to describe psychic director
that's
first yeah so and if i do it then i need
to use religious terms
and the problem is that religious terms
in our world especially are incredibly
loaded so if i use the word soul
then you might think or might think
about and then i do
and another person either god whatever
so i
try to stay as neutral and try for the
viewers
to make a little bit of an abstraction
and don't think necessarily in the
narrow terms of any religion
but in a wider meaning so when you do
psychedelics
you you have a part in your brain which
constitutes your ego and this
part is
depending which psychedelic you take is
either really reduced to zero
or at least heavily regulated down so
it's called default mode mechanism
so practically in this part of the brain
there is something which tells you you
are dave
and this is christian we have a
different history you have all the
happiness you received you have all the
pains all the scars
everything which makes dave dave is
there yeah and that goes down
again very downward or to zero and
interestingly in the same moment
you doing that something else is
emerging
or at least it's hurt maybe it's always
there philosophically but
you realize it again hear it see it feel
it
and now we can call it a soul we can
call that uh
in a voice we can call that your
subconsciousness yeah it must not
necessarily i'm not saying it proves by
the way that god is there that's another
discussion
yeah but but that is definitely 100 of
the people have
and this sort of soul um
and uh sort of universal
feeling gives you a lot of insights
so and if i try a little bit to make the
main ones the first one is
which is by the way super important i
think for everybody is um
it shows you who you really are and what
you really want
so it might sound it's a simple question
but most people don't either don't
know or they know they are afraid
of accepting it in any form it can be
simple stuff i had
people who took psychedelics who were
extremely wealthy
and realized the only thing i want to
spend more time with my family but i
didn't dare to
say it because i'm running this big
corporation or whatsoever anyway
so so it's it's it sounds by the way
everything i tell you about psychedelics
sometimes sounds super simple because
you could read it in every
um deepak chopra book yeah
but you you uh you perceive it on a
level
that it's an absolute truth you come out
of it and like okay i realize now what i
want and i'm gonna change my life
in a way that i'm happy if you're
looking for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about tech instead of
non-stop yelling check out our tech
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics
check out our full episode playlist
they're right over here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell